if this question stood like that
probably four months four out of 15 okay
but potentially by a common thing will
be part a they give you this function
right and then they say we can station
points or alternatively sure that they
are stationed points up here and here
and here okay the reason why we do that
for you is so that even if you totally
mess this up right you can use it to do
part two rival Part B so this might be
too and this might be through something
like that okay so you sort of bearing
before it depends on the kind of code on
error right so there's different things
right so talking about I mean this is
all my head right now because I'm
marking your 12 um there's carried
forward our this simplified caring for
their earth is I just heard of this
before okay so let me expand vertical
I've carried forward error right means
you've got the long question you make
some kind of basic error at the
beginning EG you read the question wrong
or you write a plus as a minus or
something like that right and then you
carry on for many lines of working which
essentially would have been right if
like there's nothing wrong with the
intervening work work out you've just
taken an error and you've carried it
forward through the rest of your working
okay if that happens like say a question
is out of four and then your final
answer totally wrong right because
you've done a lot of valid work we don't
just give you zero for that we might
give you depending on the kind of error
it is we are give you say three or if
it's a really really miniscule element
might give you three and a half it kind
of varies it's up to interpretation okay
uh simplified carried forward error
means when you make some kind of error
and I dramatically simplified the
question okay so for instance if the
question was really this like so e to
the X on X differentiate that okay and
suppose I'm you were in a hurry and you
look at X and you thought it was a fool
okay now you keep see hey people you've
done it before it faded love um you can
see that dramatically supervised
efficient right because
it's uh well or evening it's it's just
it's just that isn't it that's just it
there's nothing that's that very much
supervise the question right so you can
avoid question rule of a lot right so
even though what you've done is valid
there's an error you've carried forward
it's simplified the question right so if
it was questioned rule if it would have
been like attitude right this would
probably get a max of like other half or
one if you're being sort of nice because
a wild worked a question rule right and
you've sort of missed all of that this
stands for all the east and error this
stands for ignore subsequent error okay
so what this might mean is again a long
question right and you get to the right
answer and then say in simplifying or in
interpreting it may be or in just
writing it down you've just written it
down wrong okay so you know classic one
is where let me think I suppose you get
to something like say 44 317 to LA right
and the question was okay just
approximate it give me an approximate
answer and your your answer ends up
being something like 40 4.31 okay you
give to two decimal places okay now
depending on how big the question is how
important the approximation is whether
there are other approximation questions
in the exam and you don't want to get
hit for every single one and lose like
five marks from making the same error
repeatedly this might either be dot or
we would just look at that and forget
about it right up here if you ignore
subsequent air and give you full marks
okay because maybe all of the work
really was prior to this and you're
satisfied as you shown that you can
differentiate or put into a formula or
gravel whatever it is yeah ignore
subsequent error so you've got it right
and then you've made an error but I
McNew I'm going to ignore it and just
say I'm going to pretend I didn't see
that and give you full marks anyway or
at least you know whatever you deserve
how do you not make this power okay yeah
is that full of thing
what quality person I left it in radians
and degrees hmm and I'm look getting in
yeah again because for example it's a
good example so if you doing a Radian
measure question you had to work out
like a length or an area or something
like that and you did wrong units but
your answer ended up okay you shouldn't
present a Radian measure question in
degrees because it's raised in pleasure
right but you know most of the work is
probably and making sure you pick the
right area use the right formulas etc so
if someone's being merciful to you or
decide the rest of the paper is hard
enough and you're going to drop marks
everywhere else they might just be nice
too okay all right anyway yeah last
question yes I think last year was the
first year which had i think was 10
multiple-choice questions in the agency
and as far as i know that's the
direction it's going to head in more cuz
national curriculum blah blah blah
whatever they father actually are the
various variants they have the choice
right now there's like a whole timeline
you could look it up it's all public as
to how they're gonna like phase it in
but eventually I think it's probably
going to happen it's been a long time
coming like three or four successive
administrations have said we're bringing
in a national curriculum and well
meeting about this way this is
standardization and at the moment for
instance when you don't have
standardization across educational
systems that causes you problems because
someone says hey I have a bachelor of
education right and another guy had put
his hand up and says I have bachelor
education but if you have an Australian
beard and you had an American feared
right they are not equal so I can teach
anywhere in the world but someone who's
got a USB air can only teach basically
the US so it isn't standard across them
right and within the same country you
got same problems so New South Wales is
very strong syllabus so you could
basically go to any university in the
country if you have a new south wales
interesting right but it's not the same
if you've got a vce or a internet okay
baccalaureate international
school it's right because not accepted
everywhere you say even though it's
international yeah the high bay is a bit
strange a lot of people when the
arguments was don't do a national one
just adopt the International the I babe
right if you know about it fun that
argument awesome why they don't really
like a girl for the home because the
other states don't like that also go the
other states from every state argues
that their syllabus is the best which is
why it's their syllabus because not like
yes I am voluntarily going to take a
crappy syllabus you know one that these
are flawless well see again that's up to
debate you shame see every state says
the Australian computer is dumbing down
our curriculum every state says that
it's a bit like you know how they say
seventy-five percent of males think
they're above average and fitness so
it's like that